welcome to the program we begin in
malaysia where the top court has upheld
a guilty verdict and jail sentence
against former prime minister najib
razak najib appealed a 2020 conviction
for money laundering and corruption and
a 12-year prison term prosecutors have
said four and a half billion dollars was
stolen from the 1mdb fund which he
co-founded the court charged najib for
illegally receiving 10 million dollars
from that fund he's been on bail since
2018 pending that appeal for more on
this story let's bring in florence louis
he joins us live now from kuala lumpur
hello there florence what happened at
court today
well it's been a day of high drama at
court the hearing was originally
scheduled to go until the end of the
week now instead we heard um najib's
lawyers attempt to well file an
application asking the chief justice to
recuse herself saying that she was
biased that application was heard and
dismissed najib's lawyers also sought to
have the hearing postponed that
postponement was rejected and ultimately
we heard najib speak from the dock
itself where he again attempted to
portray himself as a victim of justice
he sought to paint the high court judge
who hurt the initial case as biased he
said the chief justice who's hearing
this final appeal is could also be
biased because on the basis that her
husband had posted critical views of
najib on social media several years ago
but ultimately the five-member panel of
the federal court um dismissed those
arguments and the you know the court
said that their findings based on what
they what they read from what the high
court said and also based on the
submissions at the court of appeal and
the written submissions that was filed
at the federal court their findings were
that there was nothing wrong with the
initial decision made by the high court
that would warrant this final court to
intervene and therefore they upheld his
guilty conviction and it also means that
his sentence of 12 years and a fine of
the approximate value of 45 million
dollars is upheld
so where to from here florence what's
next is he headed to jail
that means he will go to prison the
judge said there will be no stay of the
sentence now we are still waiting to see
what we're still waiting for najib razak
to emerge from court as far as i know
after the court was adjourned he was
seen in the dock talk speaking to
members of his family his son was there
his wife was there as well
now
he will be headed to prison um
and it's very likely that it will happen
today now he will be the first former
prime minister of malaysia to be
imprisoned now there were concerns that
because um no that is the party to which
najib belongs and this is the dominant
political party in malaysia because this
party is now back in power there were
concerns that there could be
interference in the judiciary and in
these proceedings there were concerns
that um justice may not be served um
because we've also seen in the last few
years that corruption cases involving
politicians um
[Music]
faded away because the attorney general
had decided not to pursue the cases um
so there were concerns that this could
happen now this judgment now will allay
those fears and another thing is
um because najib has long sought to
portray himself as a victim of political
persecution
that argument will hold less water now
because this judgment
is take this judgment has been delivered
with his party still in power so it's
going to become a lot more difficult for
him to argue that he is a victim of
political persecution and this is
important because remember there are
also several other cases involving one
mdb that are still ongoing against him
this particular case involves a former
subsidiary of one mdb and it's long been
regarded as one of the less complex
cases in that
whole
corruption
in that whole corruption saga
thank you for bringing us up to speed
florence louis live for us in kuala
lumpur thank you